So let's look at what the Harris
Detector algorithm looks like in
each and every step.
So, first step, we want to do for
Harris Corner Detection is compute
the horizontal and
vertical derivatives of the image.
And, again, if you recall, we have
learned how to do this in an earlier
lecture by using, basically,
how to compute derivatives, and
also doing to get towards computations
towards things like gradient images.
And another thing we want to do is we
want to actually now compute information
from the gradients to compute M.
Then, we, actually, kind of want
to smooth it out a little bit, and
that's why we take a larger
Gaussian image and
take this image that we get and
smooth it out a little bit,
because we want to kind of get more
information out of the signal here.
Then, we actually start measuring
scalar interest measure.
And I encourage you to look at more
details on where are the books that
could be available and the material
that are make available on this one.
And then, we want to basically find
maximum value above some threshold, and
those would be the features.
So, this is a step by step
method on how we can actually do
Harris Corner Detection.
Let's look at more details on this one.